Ich war am 21. August auf Urlaub in Scheibbs.
Bin dort zeitig in der Früh aufgestanden, weil ich weiterfahren wollte
und sehe auf der Straße sehr viele Gendarmeriebeamte mit Karabiner und Tornister.
Dann habe ich gefragt was denn los ist,
man sagte die Russen sind in der Tschechoslowakei einmarschiert, ja fürchterlich.
Es hat damals noch kein Handy gegeben und Telefonverbindungen waren auch nicht so wie heute.
Ich bin daher unverzüglich zum Bezirksgendarmeriekommando gegangen,
hab mich dort ausgewiesen und habe nach einem Dienstgespräch nach Horn ersucht.
Ich bin dann unverzüglich nach Horn gefahren,
hab mich in meinen Dienst gestellt und dort war die Alarmierung längst vorbei.
Es ging alles blitzschnell und hat bestens
funktioniert und alles war bereits marschbereit,
lediglich die Munition war nicht da.
Es hat 11 Stunden gedauert bis die Munition
von den Lagern geholt worden war.
Ich habe danach einen Auftrag bekommen, es hat Meldungen gegeben,
dass schwere russische Kampfpanzer sich der österreichischen Staatsgrenze nähern.
Ich musste daher mit meinem Privatauto, einem unverwüstlichen VW Käfer,
in Zivil an die Staatsgrenze und zwar nach Neu Nagelberg fahren
und mich bei der Zollwache erkundigen was da los ist.
Ich habe die Bilder der Warschauer Pakt Panzer mit gehabt, habe mich bei der Zollwache
dort ausgewiesen und meinen Auftrag gesagt, sie hatten natürlich keine Ahnung davon.
Die Leute die das angeblich gesagt haben waren längst weggefahren,
also der Auftrag war für nichts und wieder nichts.
Und es hat sich gezeigt, dass das Fehlen von Truppen an der Grenze
wirklich ein schwerer Fehler war, auch in diesem Fall hat sich das gezeigt.